so andrew tate's been trending lately
have you have you heard of the guy much
or not yes i heard him
not before you oh you never heard of him
before we started making these videos no
i guess not you're not on tick tock are
you no no you're not on any social media
so i give a quick intro to tate he's a
four-time kicks boxing world champion
over the past few months he's blown up
on social media he's now the most famous
man in the world he just got banned from
all social media platforms for these
videos so we know we'll get to watch him
and see if you agree or not i've watched
a couple what are your initial thoughts
before we go into it well at first i
gave him a zero yeah but then i improved
a little bit and i could agree with some
things he's saying okay leave the man
you love
the man you were head over heels in love
with you're going to leave him and find
another man who you don't love who's
still going to cheat on you because
you're still a trash
[Laughter]
he was talking about if you're gone if
the man cheats in a relationship if the
girl should go and leave him or not over
the fact that he cheated hundred percent
she's leaving you don't stay with a man
or a woman if they cheat on you because
if they do it once they'll do it twice
and women who marry men who have cheated
with them on their wives and now they
divorce their wives and marry them and
this is vice versa also do they think
that that person is always going to be
sincere to you also not going to happen
you have that personality to cheat to me
it's bad rotten i would throw him in the
river it would never happen twice is
that is that how grandpa died did he
actually die from cancer no he was a
good guy and he couldn't cheat because
he talked in the sleep he talked in his
sleep i would have known he never said
another woman's name when he was killed
you kidding
that would never happen he'd be in the
east river as fast as look at him
live in a world where things need to be
fair 50 50 gender equality blah blah
blah
i
pay for things unprompted you don't have
to ask me to pay for [ __ ] if we go for
dinner i'll get my wall out pay at the
end don't even check the price of the
bill my card always works just bang ouch
pay whatever no problem
unprompted if you're with me your life
is effectively free everywhere you eat
everywhere you go where you sleep you
ain't paying for [ __ ] you ain't getting
in my car and i'm asking you for
[ __ ] gas money no i pay for
everything instantly as a man should so
when you walk into a house and you see
mess
why is your lazy ass not doing the right
thing and start picking and cleaning
[ __ ] up
if you're sitting there going that's
sexist well it's sexist for me to
[ __ ] pay for everything isn't it you
[ __ ] bimbo
but that's fine
this is the whole world we live in now
double standards it's okay for me to do
the masculine thing but it's not okay
for you to do the feminine thing it's
[ __ ] women should clean
now when i say this girls go i don't
like cleaning no problem if you don't
like cleaning here how about this i'll
clean
and when i say i'll clean i mean i'll
hire someone else to clean anyway i'll
get the house clean
and you pay for everything
how about that i think a man should be a
man and maybe it's from the generation i
come from when you went out with a man
they paid for it i went out with my
husband he paid all the time i never
even gave it a second thought and for
the most part i did all the cleaning in
the house and every night he worked
every day i didn't work so i came home
and i cooked dinner and i felt that it
was my place to cook dinner but he was
not the type that said you better clean
this house or you better cook or
anything else like that circumstances
fall into that because if you're sick
you don't feel good you don't feel good
a woman should have the right to say i
don't feel good tonight i'm not gonna
cook and her husband should not say well
i pay the bills you should cook there
are circumstances involved in that
although i think a man should be a man
but unfortunately today with women
working the way that they will my
husband worked 10 jobs we i never had to
worry about anything when i needed
something i said go get another job we
need something and he did today
unfortunately it's not that way some men
just don't want it because they have to
watch football on sunday my husband
worked on sundays and i took care of the
house yeah i mean when people watch that
they'll immediately think of him as like
a tyrannical figure right but he's he's
a reasonable man
it's i agree he understands like if a
man
if the wife has covered he's not gonna
be like go pick up that
there's circumstances in every case but
basically if a man is out there working
and a woman stays home yeah the house
should be clean how's that should be
clean and there should be a meal on the
table and it's not being sexist no
there's no that's not sexist it's just a
man to pay for dinner it's just common
sense exactly based grandma but i've
decided to come out as a woman because
how i look obviously has no bearing on
the fact of what gender i am so what are
your pronouns then for the next two
hours king and lord oh stick with king
and lord all right my my appearance has
nothing to do so i mean when i was
thinking of transitioning i thought i
had to look like a girl but it turns out
i don't i can keep my shaved head in my
beard because if you assume i'm a man
for those reasons you're a bigot right
also i thought i'd have to have sex with
men but that's not i realize i can be a
lesbian woman yeah you can just identify
i can be who you want to be who the hell
cares who cares who cares yeah i don't
care who you are as long as you're not
shoving it down our throats and down our
kids throats right be who you are don't
be a criminal don't be bad as long as
you're an every good everyday person
that's all that matters exactly be a
good person and the number one way
you're going to destroy racism if you
really want to destroy it is to stop
talking about it
stop discussing it you think that's the
solution i think it's the beginning of a
solution i think if we just look at
police brutality as opposed to police
brutality versus white black asian let's
look at a police brutality right now we
have this stop asian hate thing going on
and yeah it sounds like a good idea okay
stop hating hate did you see some asian
person get beat up and it's on the
internet that i'm i guarantee yesterday
when that asian person got me up a black
guy got his ass whooped and a white guy
got his ass whooped just the same people
get ass weapons like why do we have to
put a race on the ass whooping stop ass
whoopings
why why i'd erase it stop police
brutality why out of racing why are we
adding race to everything if all you
look for is the same thing and you add a
race taint to everything then you're
gonna see racism that's how it works
that's how the world works it's like
when you buy a lambo and you thought you
never saw a lambo before now you see him
everywhere and you're mad just like
you're special and you're not it's the
same thing if all you look for and all
you talk about the same thing you're
gonna identify it right so we need to
stop all police brutality against all
people even against sexy caramel
kickboxing world champions leave me
alone i totally agree with him there i
totally agree with him also there
shouldn't be a thing with racism no
matter what color or nationality and but
it's always been there again i'm old and
we weren't so much racist with people
with color but nationalities from i mean
i am irish and italian and i was called
a mud because i'm mixed nationality and
i think being racist and i never taught
my children to be racist i was not
taught to be a racist when i grew up and
i grew up in an you know i'm 82 many
many years ago i grew up when people
didn't mix races and marriage or
religion yeah that's correct anything
and it shouldn't be you meet a person
they're a person it should not matter
who they are where they come from or
what they are if you like that person
then just be with that person black
parents are different level beat downs i
had a friend who carried a six-inch star
on his face so how'd you get that scar
he goes i pissed my mom off when my
black aunt got pissed off everyone got
beat down me my cousins any kid in the
vicinity random children let's see white
parents would be like why is this room a
mess and then they'll sit and talk about
it well timmy if you don't clean up
timmy you don't get sweets i'll try to
do some kind of business deal with a
child how to [ __ ] do a business deal
with a kid you brought this kid into the
world you're the only reason this kid
doesn't starve to death now you have to
do a little [ __ ] business deal for to
do as it's told the [ __ ] is that about
that's white parenting [ __ ] my aunt
would walk and say why is this room a
mess before anyone had a chance to
explain why it wasn't their fault
everyone got a whooping children
screaming running around the house half
naked covered in mo it was like [ __ ]
assyria that's how it went when the room
was a mess no no discussions no why no
who did it just straight beat downs in
fact black parents are so good at
raising their children i think they're
almost too good i know black guys who
legit legit will fight ten police
officers but are afraid of their mum
tate's doing good tonight i agree with
him i agree with him
i think i'd say italian parents are
pretty similar you just get a beat down
you do but i'm half irish too so i have
them both when my children did anything
wrong i pulled their hair i smacked them
and i thought nothing of it they may now
think that they were abused as kids but
they weren't they were just being
disciplined a kid is not going to tell
me what to do or do or pull a tantrum
that's not acceptable it's not
acceptable in any way slap a slap in the
face or in behind and pull the hair
never hurt anyone my kids they all have
good hair hit him with a wooden spoon
hit him with the wooden spoon that's
right that's the classic and i as a
teenager and a child until today never
ever smoked a cigarette in my life
because i was petrified that if i was in
china and i turned around and lit up a
cigarette my mother would be there
and beat the crap out of me so
tate this is a good one for you son
ain't gonna get any money because i
don't want him losing his hunger i want
him to grow up broke i wanted to go
through all the struggles i went through
i wanted to suffer i wanted to have that
fire now i had some major disadvantages
due to the fact that i had absolutely
zero access to money my family was
completely broke so i will give him some
advantages let's say like when i was a
fighter and i was fighting and i
couldn't pay the rent if my son when he
wins his fight i'll give him a financial
bonus myself for winning he still has to
go with my kids are not gonna be born
into any kind of wealthy environment in
any kind of money when i have children i
probably won't even raise them in a
western country because i think western
countries are soft bro if i have boys i
want them growing up in deep russia
yeah with like in the mountains with the
goats like just running in the snow
barefoot yeah i want monsters people
raise their kids to be soft there's too
many bulldozer parents yeah and again i
agree it's nice if you're comfortable i
mean i am not a rich woman by
no means anywhere near there but my
husband always worked and we were
comfortable but my children always
worked i gave them everything they
needed and education to a degree and
whatever but let them go out and work i
don't care if you're a billionaire or
you're not or you make 500 a week make
your children work for what they have
give them emergency money if you need it
but no my kids and even if you're giving
them money it shouldn't they shouldn't
be just slacking off and you're giving
them money if they're like really
grinding and working and you can tell
they're putting their all into it then
yeah you can help financially support
something that's totally different as i
have done i can't help my children a lot
because i don't have a lot but i'm
comfortable i'm fine but they know not
to depend on me or whatever they're
gonna get when i die because it's not
gonna they're not gonna last too long on
that no they're not hitting on car when
you're done not hitting no as a man you
are judged solely on your status you
don't even have to be good looking you
need to be important and you're only
gonna be important by achieving
important things his big thing is like
as a man you're born with nothing and
you need to earn everything and that's
how you gain status and become important
as a man well that's good and some
people like that some women are
impressed with that doesn't matter what
you look like i mean you could be you
know a gorilla looking like but some
women are after money and status that
shouldn't be the important thing be a
good person be nice and we'll be poor
together it doesn't matter i'm not poor
but you know comfortable i don't want to
be poor i know you mean
yeah working hard like if grandpa wasn't
working hard you wouldn't want to be
with him if he was just one it was a
couch potato and wanted to later on all
day i went to apply for this job
they said i need a degree i said i don't
need a degree like why didn't you go
universities because i ain't got four
years to waste from school i'd rather
get four years of experience out here
working jobs i'd rather have real
experience and money in my pocket and
learn the hard way to go to some school
and sit around and drink alcohol and do
drugs like all these other universities
i'll work for free for one week if you
don't think i'm good let you go that's
what i said i worked for free for a week
and the game is strong
he's 100 right i don't think you need a
degree for everything i myself graduated
from high school did not go any further
than high school had two very good jobs
before i got married and had children
but then my husband and i started a
business and for 30 years we had a very
successful business
no degree i learned how to do
bookkeeping i learned how to dispatch
cause i learned how to do
scheduling for everybody so i did not
have a degree and i think it's your
common sense and you're just everyday
knowledge that you can learn from not a
degree unless you're going to be a
doctor a dentist or a lawyer a lawyer
where you need where you need a degree i
don't think overall you do need a degree
except i think for personal knowledge
it's nice to have the knowledge of the
education just for personal yeah every
time i say college is a scam that's the
first thing they go to is oh but what
about doctors lawyers like obviously
that's obvious and i ran a business for
30 years with my knowledge that i got
out of high school just be yourself and
be willing to learn be willing to try
and learn and sacrifice on your own
without being in debt for two hundred
thousand dollars facts you know what's
crazy when i said this depression thing
wasn't real do you know how many people
stuck up for depression you don't
understand i'm depressed depression's
real if it's so horrible why are you
defending it you sound like it's pr team
i thought it was ruining your life but
you are desperate for me to believe in
it you want me to believe in it you're
sticking up for it you're defending
depression trying to convince me it's
real because it's your cure-all excuse
for failure when you're depressed you
can fail in every human metric i fail at
everything but i'm depressed it's not my
fault no you're a failure that's all you
are because you're not trying very hard
depression is real but mild depression
you have to get out of it yourself and
if you're trying and doing everything
possible then go further and see a
doctor or professional you know what i
think it is i think you both are just
looking at the word depression
differently because yeah you're saying
yes depression is real you can feel
depressed but you're just saying that
you need to work yourself out of it i
think he's saying the same thing he's
like obviously you can feel depressed
but get out of it it's not it's not
something stuck in your head that you're
like that forever and that's how so many
people are convinced isn't that such a
horrible mentality to constantly tell
people that if you're depressed and
you're sad it's just a mental illness
you're stuck like that forever no and
that's how that's how most people think
though when grandpa your grandfather
died and i went to the doctor and
normally you know and he gave me
something to take
and i i took it for a week or two and i
went back to him and i said i'm not
depressed i'm nervous and i will work it
out you just went through something
horrible of course you're gonna have
feelings why do you need a pill to
masturbate right away gave me a pill to
get and i i talked myself into this you
know i said no i'm not depressed i'm
nervous i'm nervous because of my
circumstances right now but i got
through it without medication without
talking to anybody just my everyday life
i got through it and i think i did very
well with it and i think that's the
problem with a lot of people they feel
bad one day and then right away they're
depressed and everybody needs a valium
or
xanax or whatever the hell they take i
don't need that i don't take anything i
can tell you whenever i'm feeling down
or tired i look at the reasons as to why
i'm feeling that i look what did i eat
earlier today did i eat like crap did i
stick to my morning routine did i
already work out if i didn't do those
things and you know what the most most
of the time i do feel like crap it's
because i didn't do those things so then
i go i journal and i get back on track
right you know and people blame their
depression on their upbringing blame
their parents it's very simple to blame
your mother and father for not doing
this and not doing that well i did not i
had my parents taught me morals and
whatever it was not far from an ideal
upbringing but i knew as an adult i
wasn't going to live like that and i was
going to do this this this and this to
get better to better my life than i did
the best grandma crushing it
i went there and i said oh it's tandem
and we're going to strap you to
an instructor then i say wait well
strap on to a dude that sounds too gay
i'll do it myself i want to jump out the
plane by myself
like okay well there's a one week course
you've got to do blah blah
so start going to these classes
and during these classes i accepted and
i now understand that i am happy to die
having never dropped out of a plane not
only is it a bit scary of course jumping
out the plane it just doesn't look
pleasurable nothing about it looks fun
when you start the training process they
explain how you jump out and they show
you all these videos of people's
parachutes going wrong and how you have
to you know pull your emergency shoe and
all these people who die and all this
[ __ ]
but even if everything goes well when
she described it to me my instructor
she that's another thing that put me off
if you want me to jump off a plane give
me a moment
with some [ __ ] woman you don't like
that no why can't women be an instructor
of skydiving women fly planes they know
just as much as men
about this oh we gotta find another we
gotta find another video actually i will
never jump out of a plane anybody who
does i think is crazy and yeah no but a
woman should be able to give him
instructions she'll probably give him
better instructions because we're more
cautious i was getting on a plane and i
could see through the cockpit that a
female was a pilot and i took a picture
and i said most women i know can't even
park a car why is a woman flying my
plane and they banned me
no no no i can park a car excellent i
come from brooklyn and i come from the
city and we park the car it's so funny
because i've had that experience gotten
on a plane with a female pilot yeah and
i did take a second look
i take a second look goes
it's not common can i see your papers
ma'am it's not common i didn't even feel
that she didn't have the right
credentials but i was like oh my god a
female pilot if you're going on a plane
would you rather a male or a female
pilot or it wouldn't make any difference
would it make a difference now it
wouldn't but when i first saw this maybe
10 15 years ago
i was like oh my god so you you'd have
no preference at all not today not in
today's time the only thing i think if
something happened to the plane
mechanically the man would probably be a
better mechanic than the woman
and i would feel safer with the man
especially knowing my husband was such
an ace mechanic yeah that i thought that
but now hey queen elizabeth was a
mechanic in world war ii and she became
a mechanic she drove trucks and became a
mechanic way before her time yeah so it
can be
right we grow into it yeah so what's
your what's your final rating for tate
what did you give so you initially gave
him a zero i agree initially but and a
couple of things here he got a zero but
i think initially he's i agree because i
am a no-nonsense person and i agree with
him almost 100 percent on a lot of
things he said just not in the way he
says it but yeah coming from a different
generation i spoke differently but he
sounds like me i beat the crap out of
somebody when they got me mad and he
would do it too
he probably gets an 89.
he went up there a zero two and eight
wow an eight or a nine the bass grandma
it's pretty clear you raised the bass
mom
i did it on purpose
make sure to like subscribe join the
discord in my comments yeah because my
grandson has to take care of me yep
join my discord learn social media for
me i'll buy grandma a yacht
i don't need a yacht just a lot of shoes
i'm not a lot of shoes
all right thank you grandma all right
i'll see you later
[Music]
won't last long